détective, il y a une situation qui
exige le meilleur des meilleurs la nuit dernière,
une bombe à neutrons a été détournée, ils ont besoin de
vous pour infiltrer localiser l'appareil et
désarmer
ce qui était plus difficile était comme les
combats que vous connaissez et les étourdissements et des
trucs comme je veux dire vous avez tout le
des choses d'action et ils le font comme s'il
n'y avait pas de câbles il n'y avait
rien c'est la vraie affaire que vous pourriez être sur le
plateau en train de faire la scène et le son pour
la cascade et cette action ce n'est pas un
homme à priser qui se tient devant vous
c'est le  acteur c'est la chose la plus folle
qu'il regarde David Belle balle
au plafond bon bon
je veux dire se retourner sur un pied je veux dire David et
moi nous sommes battus l'un contre l'
autre pour qu'une séquence de combat soit belle
comme vraiment belle tu dois
vraiment exploser un peu Je dois planifier
de nous faire entrer ça la première fois que tu as
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire remettre un poème à
nouveau
bon à Tony Party Pelosi allez
allez passé devrait avoir quatre à
six  et il y a certains moments où oui
vous pouvez donner des coups de poing et ce genre de
choses mais ça a l'air mieux quand vous
plantez vraiment le coup de pied dans la poitrine et
renvoyez le gars ici donc vous savez
que nous comprenons juste cela et nous le faisons il
y a certains moments vous  comme oh est-ce que c'est
maintenant que c'est venu un peu dur mais tu sais que
tu reçois un petit massage et le
lendemain tu retournes au travail
quelques spectac possibles pour l'insomnie le
gigantesque bien sûr